según el nivel de actividad el corazón
late entre 60 y 100 veces por minuto
esta cantidad se puede incrementar
cuando se realiza ejercicio físico o se
puede disminuir cuando se está en reposo
una frecuencia y ritmo cardíacos
normales garantizan el suministro de
sangre rica en oxígeno a todos los
órganos del cuerpo tales como el cerebro
y los pulmones
un grupo de células en el corazón
denominado sistema de conducción
cardíaco utiliza impulsos eléctricos
para controlar la velocidad y el ritmo
de cada latido del corazón
a un ritmo cardíaco anormal denominado
arritmia se produce cuando hay un
problema con el sistema de conducción
cardíaco la taquicardia es un tipo de
arritmia en el cual el corazón late
demasiado rápido la fibrilación es un
tipo de arritmia en el cual el corazón
late de forma irregular y podría ser
demasiado rápido
para determinados tipos de arritmias
puede ser necesario un procedimiento de
ablación con catéter para impedir que el
tejido del corazón ocasiona la arritmia
después de adormecer un área pequeña en
la ingle con una aguja el médico
introduce a un tubo hueco corto
denominado vaina de catéter en la vena
femoral
luego inserta un tubo largo y flexible
denominado catéter a través de la vaina
el médico guiará el catéter hasta el
corazón a través de un vaso sanguíneo
que va al corazón denominado vena cava
inferior
se monitorearán la ubicación y el
progreso del catéter
cuando el catéter llega al corazón el
médico lo guiará a la zona que está
causando la arritmia
el médico encontrará las áreas
problemáticas utilizando un mapa 3d de
última generación del corazón del
paciente
la punta del catéter emite energía
caliente
o energía fría para extirpar el tejido
en esta área la ablación hace que el
tejido deje de funcionar
para una arritmia auricular el medico
extirpa el tejido auricular que la
ocasiona si los tejidos afectados son
pequeñas áreas bien definidas el
procedimiento se llama ablación focal
o si los tejidos afectados son áreas más
grandes con alteraciones de ritmo más
complejas el médico puede realizar un
procedimiento denominado remodelación
por ablación
ambos tipos de ablación restauran los
impulsos eléctricos normales y previenen
que se produzca una arritmia
si la causa de la arritmia se encuentra
en el ventrículo el médico puede
realizar una ablación focal
o remodelación por ablación para tratar
las arritmias más complejas del
ventrículo